i think cimulu is going to be on that
same track
but he has to stop doing i he doesn't
have to what i mean is like i feel like
for me as somebody who wants to be a big
fan of his who is going to support and
root for him
you're getting so caught up in social
media [ __ ] you're doing kid [ __ ] right
now
you're you're trying to be the social
media warrior
cut that [ __ ] out social media is also a
tool it's not for you to always voice
your personal opinions about every
little [ __ ] thing you don't have to
so like like in five
four i did it again
three two i did the korean way again two
one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast i am
your host david soh and i have my
co-host for the day ed park what's up
instagram ed parkvp if you guys are
listening to this podcast for the first
time welcome you are going to either be
surprised you're going to hate me but
most likely i'm gonna leave an
impression on you you stupid [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but uh thank you guys for joining in on
another [ __ ] episode cheers i got my
wine up today
my man has his vodkas my vodka
dude did you see uh
did you see the pictures of kim jong-un
dude he looks so sweet
like a k-pop star you know what the sad
thing is when i saw that i was like it
reminds me of myself yeah
you know we also both lost a lot of
weight yeah so when i see that i'm like
holy [ __ ] all those like kim jong-un
jokes the same yeah now i'm i don't know
i'm at a crossroads like i'm kind of
happy for them
that's [ __ ] funny we're like we feel
uh morally just like this obscurity
right now it's like hey [ __ ] this guy
bud i'm really proud of you man
[Laughter]
our personal pain i relate to being fat
i get it dude you lost some weight i
literally thought that guy was gonna die
in the next five years being that big
but now he's like yeah i don't know well
who knows maybe he's losing weight
because he's sick you see that and that
the the photo that they have of him he's
in a lighter colored suit because he
lost weight
isn't
yeah he doesn't have to hide the curse
yeah i'm going to wear some gray yeah
maybe it's like a light pen
if you notice his hair cut his fades a
lot cleaner yeah dude he flew over like
a mexican or black barber over there
vince the barber just kind of faded him
up real quick
blow up that's [ __ ] funny man yeah
when i saw that i felt that weird
emotion is like
[ __ ] him but hey good for you bro
getting that health in check are you on
keto
he hoards all of the the pork and all
the pigs just to himself all that good
pork belly maybe he just decided to lose
white ego so this is what it's like to
starve yeah
i just wanted to know what my people are
going through oh
yeah man that kind of hurts
but it's not a big deal you know look at
me i look at pewdiepie yeah i did it i
didn't why you died yeah i looked so
nice now i finally listened to the uh
the the young me park podcast all the
way through right it's pretty [ __ ]
intense man yeah it's crazy it's weird
because when i was younger i remember my
dad um
you know because like all the churches
would do
you know fundraisers for north korea and
stuff my dad had videotapes of somebody
who
when i look back at it now i thought it
was like some kind of like documentary
it wasn't a documentary i think it was
people who went over there and they um
recorded what it was like living in
north korea because it was on vhs tapes
so when i was looking at this video as a
kid i thought it was a documentarian
that put this out but i think uh
somebody my dad was working with went
over there and recorded it and brought
it back or something wow
so i [ __ ] had that memory when i was
listening to the the full young me park
podcast i was like i remember i walked
in and the only reason why i remember
this [ __ ] is because there was a
recording of how they were living in the
villages and there was a lady that was
washing herself
like washing her clothes in the [ __ ]
river yeah right and she was watching in
the river or pond or something like that
and then she was like topless and then
my mom looked at my dad she goes you
like watching the [ __ ]
you're being a voyeurist on your
what the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
it's like yeah it's like national
geographic you know no it really was
like that my dad's just like look at
this like look how sad they live and
then my mom gets jealous and she goes
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah i like watching bony starving women
still at that age my goodness but i was
cracking up because when i was listening
to that podcast it's weird how these
these things just spark a memory yeah i
completely forgot about this [ __ ]
memory and then it just hit me i was
like holy [ __ ] that wasn't a documentary
that was somebody who he was working
with or it was like the church you know
korean community that they're working
with to to fundraise and raise awareness
yeah they recorded or smuggled out like
videotapes of this [ __ ] it was on a vhs
that my dad was watching wow yeah damn
my sister was actually in north korea
when kim jong-un oh kim jong il died
so she was there for the crazy big like
funeral [ __ ] where they were all
pretending to cry yeah she was there for
that that's what it sparked my memory
because i was like oh [ __ ] i forgot sora
went to north korea she was in north
korea when it happened yeah and she she
like saw from afar like this the lines
of people
and the person she was with do you
remember in the news kenneth bae he's
from washington state too i mean it was
a coincidence that got murdered no no
it's an older korean man he's like he
was like a missionary in north korea but
he was doing like tours but what he was
really doing was like sending
missionaries into north korea so he was
in prison for a while and then then they
brought him out so i was like holy [ __ ]
my sister was reading news like oh my
god like
does she wonder if she was going to get
a guide
was she wondering if she was going to
get out
a bit i think i i don't remember the
story but i'm sure she said they're that
they were just like let's get out of
here like asap oh and they they just
kicked you guys banned them all out to
get out i don't know if they kicked them
out but they might have cut and cut
their trip short because i think she was
mainly in china yeah and then she was in
north korea for like a couple weeks when
i was watching um some footage it was on
youtube and somebody was doing like tour
stuff right and obviously they did
voiceovers after the fact
and so they were talking about or you
could see footage of
this fabricated village
this fabricated food like when you look
from afar yeah it looks like a banquet
but when you get closer it's all dusty
yeah it's not even real food yeah like
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] you know what i
mean oh for sure so like when i was in
china too i went to the border along the
river
um like so like east
east northeast china
and then um
looking at north korea from the other
side and i'm looking through binoculars
and there's a city there right and you
see trucks and people walking around
but then our guide was like just stay
here for longer keep watching them right
and you know what it's the same truck
going in circles
and it's the same people just doing
menial [ __ ] like carrying things to
one place put it down
and then they pretend like pretending to
do to be doing [ __ ] just so
fishing and there's no line yeah
so if you look closely they're just like
these [ __ ] background actors dude
just doing this weird loop
it's [ __ ] crazy that's why i was
talking about you know we mentioned on
the podcast i remembered what the
drama's name was it's called it was
crash landing on you yeah okay yeah
that's why that [ __ ] was so stupid to me
yeah of course like she what if she
lands she's like i'm hungry i'm starving
like so are we
do you have any food you say
you look delicious
it was like the concept that [ __ ] was so
crazy dude i think i also heard like a
couple north koreans got caught watching
that
and they were sent to prisons
for watching the kdrama that drama in
particular
really yeah
we did a metric
on um i think just kidding films did a
metric years ago and then you could see
where you're getting viewership from we
had one viewer in north korea what yeah
what where do you get the internet you
guys like the internet dude that's why i
got hella scared because i always
imitate kim jong-un i bet it's kim
jong-un he's the only one with the
internet
you think you're so funny
that's not how i talk maybe he was just
like googling himself and then
he's like oh what am i doing there
say would my life be like if i was
american that's what kim jong-il was
that was the character what would his
life be like if he had if you lived in
the stage that's crazy i'm pretty sure
it was him you'll hear something so
funny so uh years ago and i was just
talking about this uh
with a homie of mine but there was a
stand-up comic at the time years ago
that i think i told you about this guy
but
i'm pretty sure he's fine with me now
but back in that he [ __ ] did not like
me right i actually didn't know who he
was
i didn't know anything about him so we
had a college show together out in
berkeley and there was it was it was a
korean event so all these different
korean performers were out there and at
the time i already met them before but
dumb was at the show too as well
and so um
i was being i was the headliner
and then he was before me right his set
was so [ __ ] funny like i was an
instant fan and like this dude is
[ __ ] hilarious cracking the hell up
so one of our mutual friends introduces
me to him
comes up
and i'm about to shake his hand i'm like
hey bro
the name's david and he just like
straight up
kind of like swatting my hand away
and
i remember this moment because my blood
just started boiling and you know when i
was younger i was way more
short-tempered for sure and i think like
when you
something happens here right especially
as a guy when you kind of let your guard
down and you give somebody praise you
let you let your ego go away especially
because we're in the same field as
stand-up comedy and so i was just
excited for him right when there's
somebody who's dope out there i don't
give a [ __ ] i never look at these people
as competition i just am happy to see
somebody in the space that is an asian
american who i think is a [ __ ] funny
stand-up comic right go up he [ __ ]
straight up disses me
i don't know who this guy is and i
instantly get mad right and i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] and i start walking up to
him and after this is after he turns
back and walk away and then abe grabs me
all right maybe it's my manager by the
way he grabs me he goes hey you can't do
sacramento [ __ ] here i was like no this
bull wants if he wants to [ __ ] scrap
let's [ __ ] go right and it's like
you're supposed to go up next yeah i'm
like i'm gonna [ __ ] this guy up real
quick and the funny thing is it would
have been the funniest fight on earth
because this dude looked exactly like me
yeah
it would have literally been people
wouldn't have know he's like how was
david still beating his own ass like it
would have just been this weird fight
because we looked exactly alike see
that's why i don't understand some of
the uh comments from our last podcast
when we were dissing we weren't dissing
we were critiquing
uh chongqi
and then they were saying you know like
they were comparing you to seamus like
you guys are two different
type of people i can understand the beef
you're having with this guy because you
guys are like we look exactly like
we honestly too it's like if if if
somebody told me to go [ __ ] myself i'd
[ __ ] him
you know yes
sorry yeah
so
you know it's so weird and by the way
let me just tell you just right now i
still like the guy
yeah i still really like it because it
doesn't change the fact that he's
[ __ ] funny yeah and the reason why i
bring this up is because he had this
funny-ass stand-up bit
and uh it was a standard bit about him
he went to go to
to south korea to go to the dmz the
demilitarized zone yeah and he said that
when he was there he remember he grabbed
some binoculars to look over what was
going on and he saw a north korean guard
he looked at him and was like what
because he thought he was kim jong-un
like what the [ __ ] how's he over there
and that [ __ ] had me dying and you know
even after that altercation
i still like this comedy i didn't
personally like him as a person at that
point um but what was explained to me
specifically by dumb because dumb is a
friend of his as well he was like at the
time
a lot of stand-up comics found youtubers
as
just lazy competition it's like how come
i get to be on this scene as a stand-up
comic for x amount of years you get to
step in and then you're the headliner of
the show i deserve this more than you
and i guess at the time too i didn't
know this because i stopped watching mad
tv at this point but he actually used to
feature on mad tv because he's a friend
of bobby lee's and he used to play uh
kim jong-un
and i had the kim jong-il yeah i didn't
know this i've never seen his [ __ ]
right
so how could i have copied this also by
the way bro
you're not the you're not actually kim
jong-un
there's a lot of people who did
impersonations yeah there's a lot of
people who do impersonations of every
single one of our presidents exactly
right so i you know i i do understand
where he's coming from especially
because he's worked so hard to be where
he was at and you know for this new wave
to come in of a bunch of youtubers who
you know seemingly are taking his spots
that he feels that he deserves
especially a guy who looks exactly like
him yeah he's gonna feel a certain way i
just felt like at that time i wish he
would have approached it differently
because i wanted to be his friend
yeah i'm not gonna lie i heard him
uh call you an editor yeah he just said
you know why are you so why is he so big
just because he's good at editing videos
yeah and i think what he didn't like at
the time too is that i did that stand-up
set and i'm [ __ ] killed yeah but he
doesn't know i've been doing stand-up
almost just as long as him yeah
he did not he doesn't know that though
right it's like a person a kid who just
did youtube just can't start doing
stand-up i started doing stand-up when i
was 16 [ __ ] years old he was never
there right so it's like
the idea that people kind of create
these fake enemies out of their head to
justify as justify justifies justify how
they feel about somebody because maybe
they felt like they're being dipped out
sucks because at the time i i could have
even looked up to him because i thought
he was that great of a stand-up and i
still think he's a great stand-up you
know but it was one of those things it
was like he felt that i was competition
and there was never competition
everybody can eat out here yeah
everybody can and if anything else if we
banded together how funny of a sketch
could we have made it yeah it would have
been so [ __ ] funny yeah i'm there was
actually someone who proposed this
sketch idea to me because he's friends
with the other guy yeah
and then he was like yo can you can you
get david to you know do this skit with
us and i was like well what is it right
it's with him and you
and it was a skit of you guys at the
same audition oh how funny would that
have been and you guys were having an
argument it never went through i guess
they never made it but yeah i mean it
would have been great but he he didn't
like me at the time yeah i heard he's
like he's okay with me now but
i just didn't understand it's like bro
i've never done anything to you and if
anything else i should have had your
respect because i've been doing stand-up
just as long as you have but once again
he didn't know and you know when you
already have a preconceived notion about
somebody and you assume what they were
and what they've done without having a
conversation with them or let them know
even just researching a little bit
sometimes you don't have to have the
conversation but he could have just
asked around and people would have told
him he's been on the stand-up scene for
a long time since he was a kid because
at that time i was what 24 years old 25
maybe no 25 years old so that's nine
years in already yeah nine years in as a
16 year old so i i wish
at that moment it didn't happen that way
but if somebody asked me now oh do you
think he's funny i'm like yeah he's
still funny yeah i just wish he wasn't
so mean to me
you know
it's the same way i feel about phil
wickham
sometimes i just can't stop listening to
his music he's just an [ __ ] you know
like
i mean i think he's still a really cool
yeah i'll say his maybe you guys
probably know he fires his name is danny
cho yeah i love danny cho dude like if
you look he was he did a set on kim's a
comedy i thought his was like the
funniest one all right his set was so
[ __ ] funny man no i've been there to
a couple of shows he's [ __ ] hilarious
he's hella funny dude it was just like
the the way he felt about you because
you know at the time i was living in
cape town i was pretty i'd seen him a
lot that there was like he was always
that blue yeah between he and he and i
and like whatever it was always whatever
cool but then it was just like man but
why do you feel this way
like what what did david do yeah right
like did i steal your material i didn't
do any of that stuff i didn't steal any
of your [ __ ] i i only knew about him at
that show and i started watching a
stand-up and i just thought he was the
funniest dude so like always you know
wishing success upon somebody like that
especially because he's another korean
dude he's another asian guy and i think
at the time like even for me i was
always hyper critical of other asian
comics yeah who would just do the
typical asian jokes but didn't have a
lot of nuance he always had nuance he
would always talk about where he's from
and
how he grew up as a korean guy and i
just thought he was just so [ __ ] good
at what he did yeah so i heard he's
doing stand-up comedy in korea now he's
like he's like spearheading stand-up
comedy in south korea remember i seen
clips of that where he goes up there and
then he does stand up like because stand
up is fairly new in in south korea right
because usually comedy shows are like
they're more snl ish
they're like
yeah slapstick and like way goofier but
he's just doing the thing where he's up
there and then they just speak and when
they speak people
you know react not to a gag or a
kind of goo it's very charlie chaplin
stuff out there for the longest time so
if you guys watched like years ago uh
south korean uh comedy shows
very prop heavy mm-hmm um a lot of exact
very theater-like it was like old-school
korean theater yeah you know and those
were and they were it's so [ __ ] funny
and there's a lot of korean word play
um
danny cho is out there spearheading the
thing of hey we don't need this we can
be funny with just our words and our
stories yeah and he's like one of the
bigger dudes out there from what i've
heard which is kind of cool because i
didn't even know he could speak korean
that well his korean is [ __ ] hella
good
well he's also like i remember he was
telling me too he's actually a like a a
black a taekwondo black belt
like in what world
he grew up in east l.a and he grew up
doing taekwondo that makes sense we all
did taekwondo yeah i was a red belt
stripe yeah so i'm i have huge respect
for him for sure like but i i think a
lot of people get confused like when
we're out here like we're just talking
[ __ ] about people
yeah and i think it's like difference i
mean you know we'll go back to this too
it's like uh we're you know we were
critiquing um
or reviewing uh shanghai yeah and i went
to why do you hate shimulu so much it's
like we're talking about the movie yeah
i kept seeing comments like you're just
jealous of scene movies dude that [ __ ]
bro when i saw this i started thinking
of writing a sketch where i'm shang-chi
and it was the funniest thing ever dude
you know that scene where you take off
the shirt yeah and then you're in the
arena i just pictured me taking off my
shirt and everybody booing me
they just call you shangnom
[Laughter]
the legend of the ship
legend of the
dude that'd be a hell of funny let's do
it let's just get a green screen green
screen just do something we've done that
before
you guys can find some old [ __ ] where i
put them in batman begins oh bro we are
doing shangnom for sure yeah that's
happening next week we're filming that
[ __ ] it's been a long time
dude hella funny
yeah people are like you wish you could
be in that role it's like
how how
dude i saw some behind the scenes i saw
simulator doing
stunts
do the bus scene [ __ ] yeah he did like
some of his own stunts that was amazing
i was watching it like there's no way
you'd only get danny jo to be a stunt
dog
hey bro i know you don't like me but i
need you to hit this backflip
i i need you to hit this [ __ ]
backflip please but if you haven't
checked out danny cho check out his
stand-up man like literally one of the
funniest like korean stand-up comics out
there
you know he's killing it out in south
korea so if you're korean watch him too
but that was the thing too just when we
when we go into like these movie
critiques right they're like well why
are you hating on it so much you know
what we said about this film was no
different from the other films that
we've critiqued as well i think there
was just like an emotional thing it's
like it took it very personally
it's like
when black panther came out if there
were other black creators that said they
didn't like it they probably would have
got crucified too oh yeah but the
difference between
i think what a lot of other people are
doing and what i do is that i don't
really have an emotional tie to
hollywood or wanting to be a hollywood
star and i enjoy my life and what i'm
doing now and i want to stay opinionated
this way um and once again these are
just opinions you know these aren't
guess what you [ __ ] love it i'm glad
you love it yeah i don't have to love it
too though we're not like angry at you
guys for loving it but you guys are
angry at us for not
but you're saying we didn't hate it yeah
at the end of the i think
it's funny too because i believe a lot
of the explanation because what you know
when you look i'm like that way too when
i hear something that affects me
emotionally we we tend to block out half
of the reason that comes with um the
words that were said that hurt our
feelings yeah right so look i understand
and they're like
you wouldn't [ __ ] i watched the film
twice yeah you know even after i said i
wouldn't
you know and my opinion still stands
everything that i said in my opinion
still stands i i i saw it twice too
i i had my opinions the first time
second time i just felt more reassured
yeah and i think too it's like uh one of
the reoccurring comments of that
was um all this stuff was explained i
was like listen
we're not saying that it wasn't
explained i'm saying we're saying that
it wasn't explained well and it was and
there wasn't enough reasoning for
character motive yeah this is the the
biggest difference they go what do you
want this information spoon fed i was
like the problem is it was spoon fed
yeah yeah like like through through
through my exposition yeah we're saying
through the art of film
the golden rule is show don't tell yeah
you know there are things that we need
to see there's a reason why this it's
not shanghai the podcast one of the
arguments that i dislike when the people
bring up marvel films they go it's a
marvel film what did you expect oh my
god i regret that one too yeah you're
that means you're discrediting all the
dope [ __ ] marvel movies that have
made billions of dollars and rate like
above yeah 8.9 on like i didn't have
these issues that we're talking about
now they're like well this is an origin
film so was guardians of the galaxy
so was iron man one exactly black
panther exactly like they were all great
[ __ ] films yeah and to be honest with
you they didn't have the same pitfalls
that this film had so i you know for me
the upsetting part is as an asian
american i think we got gypped yeah no
for sure so
um i follow so do you remember every
frame of painting yes super [ __ ]
great as video essays yeah filmmaking
loved his videos
he retired
now this other uh chinese canadian dude
does like a film uh
theory like essays right
and he's called accented media i think
or accented cinema yeah right but uh
you know he he has this like very thick
chinese uh french canadian accent but
it's very much picking up where every
frame of painting left off and he did a
shanxi thing too
and he said something that finally is
like this is what we're talking about um
the problem with shanxi being that it
perpetuates the the foreigner aspect of
asian americans that we are the
perpetual foreigner that we don't
actually belong in america
because the way chiang chi is portrayed
it's not
fully an asian american film
you know because in asia he's in they go
to asia essentially saying he's going
back the journey is going back home
and the whole setting of the film too is
celebrating chinese cultures chinese
history chinese mythology right not what
makes us asian american right and the
things we deal with
pretty much here in america because if
you also noticed
none of the stakes were held against
us as americans
or anyone in san francisco all of the
stakes happened in an imaginary world
just like narnia because what happens
when they leave narnia and come back to
the regular world it's just like they're
broken or yeah or even harry potter all
the crazy [ __ ] really happens at
hogwarts you know
it there's no real stakes to the real
world they just have to keep it secret i
feel like the satisfaction meter for a
lot of asian americans who feel like
they haven't been able to see
you know people who they could really
envision as a hero
the satisfaction bar is a lot lower
they're like well you talk about they
they talked about you know oh my mom
would have loved to have a daughter
who's studying at this bus like that
touched i was like that's all it took
for you guys to feel that you're seen in
here there's one joke yeah and you know
it could have hurt anywhere on so many
other shows and tvs and movies yeah so
maybe the standard is different right
but i i just you know i think we love
watching film and we've seen so much
like asian american cinema and film
that
for me it just wasn't enough yeah
because
i hate people saying it's good enough
we're better than good enough yeah like
we are so much better than [ __ ] good
enough and i just i get tired of hearing
that stuff like why why is it is it
i mean how many people is it but it's
it's the vocal
you know people in the comments but like
why not have excellence yeah why can't
we be excellent yeah you know why can we
be why is it good enough because it
reminds you of your parents giving you
[ __ ] you know maybe we're that way
that's what we expect yeah you know
sorry i went to a big event with a bunch
of asian actors and to be honest with
you a lot of them agreed with it you
know and i think like one of the things
that
um
one of my buddies said he goes yeah man
like i agreed with most of your stuff
there's some stuff i disagreed with but
in all honesty if we don't critique
ourselves and we don't expect ourselves
to elevate from what's given to us then
how do we get better so same thing my
friends said the same thing they were
like i felt
off leaving it like i'm supposed to like
it but they were saying you know after
they heard our podcast that it was like
oh that's why i did it like yeah that's
what a lot of my friends who words what
we were feeling yeah they were like
that's so that's so [ __ ] crazy
because i had
three friends that said that through uh
instagram dms they're like you know what
bro when i left i f i liked it but i
couldn't express why i didn't right you
know and they were like that's what it
was like it just they felt uneasy about
it it's like this
loyalty to enjoy this film right which
once again
based on the action alone
i highly recommend to watch this film
yes i never said you shouldn't watch the
film i think you should it's not a
[ __ ] green lantern all right
yeah it's not that you know it's not
green lantern like marvel still has
higher standards than a lot of superhero
movies exactly so is it a terrible film
no but there was a lot of stuff that i
disliked about it and i felt like that
you know as a review we have to nitpick
on these things it was missing a lot
because like think about what we've been
going through in this past year
you know with uh the china virus or even
like uh
asian attacks the stop asian hate stuff
right dude shanxi is an illegal
immigrant
there should be a story about him
getting his legal status he's a dreamer
dude he should have been about daca
you know touch on those subjects keep it
in america yeah like here's the thing we
know that he's gonna have a trilogy you
know we know he's gonna be in an
avengers they might touch this stuff
yeah you know so it's like okay
it'll come we'll wait it's interesting
because
um a few other comments that i was
reading too and i typically don't read
comments like this in depth but
this was a fun thing because i actually
got to talk with people in the comments
back and forth and it was completely
cordial and i understood what they were
saying and they understood what i was
saying and it was dope it's actually
what i kind of wanted right yeah but the
one of the things that people were
saying that i disagreed with but like
what did you expect this to be like a
sundance art film like why is it that
doesn't have to it doesn't have to be
this is just basic stuff that i think
that every film should hit yeah you know
very much like
i was so disappointed with the fact that
they were the same people at the end
that they didn't change
because like that's just not the hero's
journey this is a superhero film yeah
this guy doesn't like seem to learn or
change a bit one of the things is like
what you would say what do you mean he
didn't change didn't you see that um
he [ __ ] uh was the guy he went with
like benedict wong into the other i was
like what the [ __ ] does that have to do
with growth no he got invited into the
whole marvel sphere he's like oh you're
in for a big right now you thought that
was crazy it's gonna be crazier for you
but it's like
where does he why is he important yes
and i think it once again it boils down
to what
a lot of people were just okay with
right but one of the things that i also
really disagreed with was hey we've
never had asian heroes on the big screen
and i'm like then why the [ __ ] does
everybody talk about this man on my wall
right now bruce lee
are the people who came after him
exactly
so [ __ ] bruce leathen huh yeah what
about harold and harold and kumar yeah
[ __ ] john
why
but this is what i'm saying like
we just people were going crazy about
tarantino because of how he portrayed
bruce lee in his film yeah and everybody
was up in arms about it because of their
hero growing up was bruce lee yeah and
then now the narrative is that i never
grew up with asian male heroes masculine
asian heroes
what the [ __ ] were you saying about
bruce lee you [ __ ]
you know what i mean like it's so weird
how you can elevate this new marvel hero
but you could but then you [ __ ]
on what other people have done before
this character yeah right so i i
disagree with that we have had plenty of
strong male age not plenty i'm sorry
not a whole lot but we have had it not
not to the point of like complaining
this much jackie chan
jet li
you know what i mean yeah there's just a
lot of stuff too like once again i
enjoyed that people i love the
conversation the character is the kung
fu master right and so that has to be
part of his play you know it's just that
you know his story should have been in
america that i think that's i would have
completely liked that a lot too yeah
like it
it it could have touched on the talos
stuff sure a whole lot but what if
you know uh when moo came to america
and he started some [ __ ] and he started
[ __ ] around with the idea of like
perpetuating asian hate maybe his
actions was causing people to blame you
know immigrants because of these things
like these are real topics to touch on
that they could have they didn't they
didn't touch it they just wanted to
please
once again it's it's it's not a sundance
film though and so you can't we can't
really do that you know but i think it's
okay like i think it's okay for us no
it's more than okay we should expect
better things right if i've enjoyed
marvel films i want that same level of
attention and care i will never ever
forgive them for putting him in vans
jeans and some van sneakers
and that bejeweled top i will never
forgive the costume designer for that
right and you know even to go into this
marvel there's nothing wrong with the
casting either i think they cast the
film pretty [ __ ] good yeah i think
marvel's
best attribute is whoever's casting
marvel films you do such a [ __ ] good
job like who else could have filled
cbl's role actually i don't know he does
martial arts he does stunts he's a
canadian american or asian american
right yeah
casting's great aquafina played the
awkward goofy sidekick partner who else
would you have casted for that role i
don't really know so the casting was
great it's just the film i didn't really
like as much yeah you know it had
everything but
someone didn't seem to double check on
the story yeah yeah it was very much
that's everything we were talking about
we weren't knocking on like anything but
what happened was with that the night
you know when i
a couple of my friends were talking
about it too they're like they're i'm
pretty sure it's it's they're hardcore
fans of simu right because we did a
previous podcast
to talk about this topic too it was when
um
simulu recently is under a lot of fire
because he used to be a reddit in cell
you know oh no you know he was the the
you know by the way like reddit's cool
like those forums are really dope i
can't spend enough time on that [ __ ]
yeah so he was one of those people that
had an honest anonymous account that
just kept writing his opinions and
thoughts about everything right he was
the prototypical reddit incel and for me
it makes sense now it's like this is why
in every single one of his social medias
he's always [ __ ] on somebody he's
always like chastising people like
you know trying to be the hero of the
morality police exactly and you know it
i was reading this article too what they
were talking about they brought up a
tweet from him from like 2019 where he's
saying listen i'm not perfect i'm going
to say stuff but people have an ability
to change and grow 100 true however the
reason why he's getting burned out too
is because
you are now a hypocrite because you
don't show people that same amount of
grace so when you put yourself up on
this moral high ground you're going to
have to stay there yeah you can't be up
here look down at everybody and then
when you [ __ ] up you say well people can
change you have to give people that same
grace
you know which is going to be his
biggest flaw right the other thing too
is for him like
when you're on reddit then one of the
best things about reddit is that you can
stay anonymous
he chose not to stay anonymous once he
got a name to himself he goes people
need to know who this is
why cmu why why do that
why
why
so notoriety notoriety or something
right because
you know and i and i said this too
there's a little bit of narcissism
involved in this right yeah it's for you
to go on an anonymous platform and feel
that now that you have a name it's like
well people need to know who these
opinions are coming from because it's
gonna mean more now that they know it's
from me the star it's like bro
be quiet
please like you are now
the face of asian american males right
this is what you wanted well once again
you did that and then you're so busy
chastising everybody else letting know
everybody know how much of a piece of
[ __ ] they are
well guess what now you have this moral
standard that you always have to abide
by because people are going to come
after you now bro dude i came across the
subreddit he was on lurking on and
commenting on
uh like in 2014 or something something
way back when i first got on reddit and
i just remember it being so sad
and so whiny
it's basically just asian dudes
complaining about asian women dating
white guys
it's just it's sad you know
a couple youtubers i know yeah
it's been a while
[Laughter]
but yeah it was pretty much like he was
identifying with them really hard you
know and i was just like
damn hilarious
i came across that suburb and i was like
nah i'm not touching that [ __ ] that's
the thing like i i've had places where i
am just angry
with the environment i was in because i
was in the bum [ __ ] middle of nowhere
with a bunch of racist methods getting
fetishized by some colorado hillbilly
yeah
for real
and it's like
the last place i wanted to find solace
is but those [ __ ] yeah
and
just being angry at people for the sake
of being angry you know and listen when
you when you go through a lot of like
trials and tribulations specifically
when you're getting bullied because of
the way that you look speak in your
culture it's easy to harbor hate but
when we start doing blanket things and
condemning everybody how are you any
better yeah you know yeah you can't just
start generalizing everyone's like that
everyone's like yeah like you you
experience this annoyance like multiple
times you know more often than people
should but then
it's not healthy to actively seek other
people who share the same kind of like
hate or anger or whatever that's not
healthy so if you guys are also
wondering too like the the comments that
he made under his originally anonymous
reddit was that he decided to put his
opinion on the idea of what a pedophile
is right and he wanted to show sympathy
to pedophiles because they are human
beings so when you read this whole thing
in context he is trying to eloquently
say like hey let's care about our human
people who what science is showing that
pedophiles actually have a disruption in
their gene or something like that i'm
not using the right uh scientific terms
i'm not a scientist mutation in their
genome yeah that causes them to be
pedophiles so just like being gay
just like just like years ago we didn't
realize that people were just born gay
so it's pretty much the same thing yeah
is what it was coming off as in my mind
i'm thinking what made you think that
this was a smart thing to [ __ ] say
yeah why it's like
a lot of people were gonna figure out
who it was because he was still
anonymous in the post yeah but he said i
recently played a pedophile on this show
that or whatever yeah i think and people
put put it together that it's him yeah
and look
whether we have an opinion on what he
said or not it's just
literally how the media
was gonna eat that [ __ ] up
um
shows a lack of foresight yeah yeah for
himself it's it's it's
why
what are you doing yeah you know it's
like what are you doing
shut the [ __ ] up and then like later in
different posts saying hey i'm simulu
yes
why
why you do this yeah i can't like i'm
trying to root for you dude but you keep
doing stupid [ __ ]
cut it out i'm not telling you like the
[ __ ] ann coulter lebron james comment
just shut up and dribble a ball i'm not
saying that
but bro you
i feel like he thinks that his opinion
is law like he needs people to
understand how well versed and woke he
is on these subjects they don't need to
but that's the exact thing about
wokeness that's why i keep saying
wokeness is a theology
that it's not
like because there is no woke bible yet
right our society today is just debating
online and there's no real world
constitution yet though yeah right so
this [ __ ] is just theory and what you
have out there though is an echo chamber
on twitter or wherever you want to voice
your opinions on it
to have a
this different perspective or whatever
but you gotta
i don't know put your name to it and all
these things you're really risking
yourself with having a thought like this
yeah and then also too i mean he also
got burned and a lot of like
asian women are coming forward because i
guess they
once they knew who he was in this space
they knew that person who would write
these comments and they were trying to
dig up older reddit posts that he did
you know topics of him having an opinion
on women and now they're calling him a
misogynist once again this is a legend
i've never read them i can't agree with
this yeah you know but
there there was a post where he talked
about what was it it was the whole
unpopular opinion thing or
yeah that was subreddit i'm popular in
popular opinion it's like i hate playing
sports with women because they're weaker
than us yeah i'll say some stuff too
and then the last line is come on guys
you guys are with me yeah are you guys
with me it's like
someone backed me up here shut just shut
the [ __ ] up like why did you do this
play in an old men's league then dude i
know but like you have to understand too
it's like this is what i was talking
about you have to understand the level
of narcissism that you have to have to
want to write this and still have people
just
want to give you praise for being extra
awoke or giving people alternative
thought
simul if i could ever give you some
advice right
opinions do matter but first thing is
first
get off your [ __ ] moral high horse
if you want to be able to condemn other
people right or have an opinion about
the stuff that they do because the the
backlash that you get from saying that
you are a person i want to be the face
of asian males and morality and how
people should treat each other
you have to follow that code to the
[ __ ] t right i always state this
before even when he and i are on this
pot when ed and i are doing this podcast
these are opinions we're always going to
make mistakes our opinions are going to
change because people are always going
to drop knowledge on us 24 [ __ ] seven
this is how we feel at the moment and by
the way too 99 of [ __ ] is jokes
so yeah we're on here because we're
trying to laugh exactly we're just we're
joking around we're laughing this is
what this podcast is for yeah that's why
we dissect deep yeah and so for him
because he put him in this position
there's no way that you're not going to
get backlash the second advice that i
would give you is shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Laughter]
just shut the [ __ ] up you are doing
amazing things right now you are the
face of an asian-american franchise your
opinion about women being weak in sports
needs shut the [ __ ] up please i beg you
i beg you be quiet because yeah i mean
there's the there are other perpetual
like stereotypes
of us being misogynist or treating our
women poorly you know i mean and then
the other thing is he's constantly like
there's a i saw a meme
i saw a meme of him shirtless with a
stunt coordinator or whatever and they
have like rock and abs they're just
[ __ ] chiseled right and then it was
something about
you know some what you say about asian
stereotypes like having abs is
anti-asian stereotype this is what i'm
saying but it's the fact that you got
into that shape to play a kung fu master
though
it's like you just gotta accept the role
man i know
this is so [ __ ] funny how are you
gonna keep speaking out against like you
know [ __ ] stereotypes when you are
now the most famous kung fu master
you know it's but once again it's just
lack of self-awareness too and once
again it's that you know he has to admit
too and other people might understand
where i'm coming from it's like it's not
a place of hate it's just like
why you do this to us man yeah like we
don't need this it's the same issue that
i had with him attacking bob chapping
when he's giving
you you're given this amazing role
that's highlighting asian americans and
you you took what this man said to
basically further your personal agenda
of making yourself look like this asian
hero yeah there is this is not even an
opinion anymore it's [ __ ] fact i'm
sorry and it's showing in a lot of the
stuff that he's doing so once again my
biggest advice to him as of right now
shut the [ __ ] up keep doing dope work
keep doing dope [ __ ] do what you're
doing right
this podcast is sponsored by hellofresh
my friends hellofresh makes home cooking
easy fun and affordable and especially
delicious and that's why it's america's
number one meal kit get better value
hellofresh is over 30 percent cheaper
than shopping at grocery stores with
pre-portioned ingredients that ensure
you won't spend money or waste excess
food that always ends up in the trash
when you follow these online recipes
hellofresh eliminates all that super
easy super delicious and guess what
everybody thinks i'm amazing chef when
your boy just following hellofresh and
by the way if you guys are worried about
if you can customize it well guess what
you can do all that stuff in the app in
minutes you can even skip a week
whenever you need to uh there's food
preferences that you can change and you
could also change your delivery day all
in the app it's super easy and if you
guys are wondering didn't you talk about
something called green chef as well
david well guess what green chef is
owned by hellofresh it just gives you
more options so go to hellofresh.com
brain14 and use code brain 14 for up to
14 free meals including free shipping
once again that's go to
hellofresh.com
brain14 and use codebrain14 for up to 14
free meals including free
shipping so remember my friends hello
fresh america's number one meal kid
thoroughly think about what you're going
to say your opinions should be opinions
and that's perfectly [ __ ] fine right
but when you go out of your way first of
all the fact that you just went on
anonymous on reddit is [ __ ] stupid
like it's like if you're gonna be
you know not anonymous then be true to
yourself who you really are yeah you
know those anonymous thoughts are like
those inside thoughts yeah they're
inside thoughts that's
you know and you thought that you were
gonna put somebody on this next woke
level of thinking right which once again
serves your personal ego yeah it's not
because you're trying to shed light on
the situation it's because you're trying
to make yourself look amazing so cut
that [ __ ] out you're doing dope things
continue to do that kill it in this
space and the rest will [ __ ] follow
it has been proven time and time again
and i truly believe this because when i
went to
so uh we went to the after party for uh
like blue bayou right right great film
great [ __ ] film um
there were
agents there there were people
in the film industry whatever i got to
meet one of my [ __ ] heroes benedict
wong right right i saw that
this man benedict wang by the way
i always talk about him on this podcast
how much i [ __ ] love him and we've
gone back and forth on dms yeah you know
although right so i never you know he
maybe he's being nice i don't know this
right yeah i'm sitting there and i'm
standing there and i'm super shy as [ __ ]
and i'm sitting across and i'm just like
oh that's benedict huang man like he
doesn't know me like we've talked here
and there we always write comments and
stuff and i'm just gonna stay over here
i don't want to say anything and he's
talking to khalif and khalifa's let you
know how much he appreciates that he
stops because he goes hold on a second
first of all thick ass uk accent
hold on mate right
he comes up to me goes you
comes up to me gives me the biggest hug
ever
i damn near cried dude i almost [ __ ]
cried that's your ticket in to the next
[ __ ]
comes up too
i damn near [ __ ] cried and you know
like
and i used him as an example of the film
of how he delivered his lines and i wish
other people would have delivered it
like how he did yeah super [ __ ] funny
very subtle didn't need to be over the
top right but once again this could just
be because of the writing of shanxi and
i don't think it's the any of the actors
faults right uh even if i thought
somebody acting a little uh but i'm just
being critical of somebody who's viewing
the film so
but once again to my point was what i
was saying is like how much the work
that you do is important not just to
yourself but how other people perceive
it
the reason why bennett wong knows who i
am is because of [ __ ]
oh
he saw that he saw [ __ ]
and it made an impression on him yeah
and so he was giving me [ __ ] he's like
why aren't you acting
you know
like wait hurt my feelings
hey like i'm opening up food businesses
right now i need to get this out the way
i have obligations towards it so you
know and then i heard from other actors
and agents they're like hey who are you
signed to right now i'm like i'm not
acting right now i was assigned to a top
five agency i'd let them know who it was
like cool you're not with them are you
acting next year i'm like not yet
they're like come on yeah
so
i'm not tooting my own horn but [ __ ] is
one of the things that i'm so [ __ ]
proud of if i never acted again i don't
give a [ __ ] because i got to create this
piece right you know with a good friend
of mine justin so
i feel like in his case it's like bro if
you do great work it's going to be
recognized you're already going to be an
undeniable person yeah stop sucking your
own dick so [ __ ] hard looking for
people to praise you for every little
[ __ ] thing you're trying so hard to
be the face of asian american men about
what it what morality is when it comes
to race relations
you being an amazing person and a good
person and being in the position that
you that you're in is going to reflect
that already yeah you can do it without
serving your ego yeah you're good look
at tom hanks you don't really know what
he's thinking at all
but we love him
you know yeah that would be my advice to
when i'm pretty sure people in this
inner circle if you guys aren't giving
him that advice you are not his [ __ ]
friend yeah you're too busy out here
reposting his [ __ ] saying like you're
doing this great what what is your inner
circle saying to you because i have my
inner circle that are always going to
bring me back down and center me i i
think that's the problem with maybe uh
the entertainment business or at least
the the performance side of it
is that once you reach some certain
status or you book a great part or you
know whatever it is you're the hot
ticket of the moment
um this is your chance yeah it's your
chance to say something now you have
authority because now you're famous or
something and it's like
when was that the case you know because
you were a famous star now you can say
some [ __ ] like
like
uh you know what i mean like not that
nobody shouldn't have to feel this way
but then when you're saying one thing
about representing all of us and then
saying [ __ ] that doesn't represent all
of us yeah that's a detriment who said
that we wanted you to represent all of
us why are you putting this why do you
get the [ __ ] wc belt heavyweight belt
of all time of asian men like nobody
asked you to do this nobody's saying
that you need to
i think what we want is just for you to
be excellent at the stuff that you're
doing and it's going to reflect on us
really well especially during this time
when we are being seen and we are being
heard
so i feel like he's the biggest person
that's getting in his own way
right you keep doing this stuff and you
once again you keep serving your
personal ego instead of doing the the
task at hand which is you being an
amazing artist
right
yeah you're getting in the way yourself
look at stephen yoon
um he's an amazing actor
right and he has his opinions which as i
think seema was super entitled to about
asian masculinity asian film or whatever
but he does it through his work and then
when his work shines and then he speaks
up because there's a foundation for it
it hits heavier with us yeah right
i think simulu is gonna be on that same
track
but he has to stop doing
he doesn't have to what i mean is like i
feel like for me as somebody who wants
to be a big fan of his who is going to
support and root for him
you're getting so caught up in social
media [ __ ] you're doing kid [ __ ] right
now
you're you're trying to be the social
media warrior cut that [ __ ] out social
media is also a tool it's not for you to
always voice your personal opinions
about every little [ __ ] thing you
don't have to so like like a hammer is a
tool but it can also be a weapon yeah
right same way social media is a tool
yeah but then you don't always have to
weaponize it man he's following the
likes you know that's why he put up the
thing asian american males are what like
asian people haven't had abs
the [ __ ] are you talking i personally
don't know what it feels like
i'll tell you what man i've had abs and
you know what it didn't make me happier
you know i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna
have cards i've never seen somebody so
happy
eating
danny spaghetti in my life
like this fool was in prison for 20
[ __ ] years and he finally came out
and he ate something else aside from
melted hot cheetos and government cheese
the way you eat daddy's spaghetti is
like somebody eating the the finest a5
wagyu prime steak ever for sure like
when i when i go to like really
expensive italian restaurants and i i'll
have to order the spaghetti i get upset
because it's like not denny's
and he'll stop his meal he goes somebody
bring the [ __ ] chef out
compliments to the [ __ ] chef
yeah did you boil these noodles yeah my
men
did you overcook these noodles just the
way i like it
it was a little yeah it was a little bit
chewy yeah
i love it
you my men are doing god's work [ __ ]
kisses the guy yeah well guys that wraps
up this episode of the genius brain
podcast um hope you enjoyed that
conversation once again i'm gonna always
root for you know a lot of these asian
americans that are out there that are
you know in the front of media but i'm
always gonna have an opinion about what
they do yeah you know i don't think that
he's handled the bob chapped situation
very well and i wish he just wouldn't
have gone on the in-cell reddit rants
yeah but once again it is what it is
have some forgiven forgiveness in your
heart if you're going to [ __ ] on people
24 7 and go get on your moral high horse
it's easier for people to take you down
humanize yourself a little bit bro
you're human too i understand we all
make mistakes and if you want people to
give you that same grace you have to
give it out to people as well
amen yeah
now let's all pray together
well you can find ed at ed parkvp
check him out on his instagram um you
can obviously catch him on the genius
brain podcast episodes every thursdays
and sundays all the way up till this
december in january we are going once a
week um so enjoy that once again we're
not leaving but once a week in january
and there's going to be another project
that's going to come up that you guys
will hear about as well um i don't even
know about this you got to tell me after
we'll see y'all next time peace